des politiques ce matin c'est fabien
roussel bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos députés du nord
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
est candidat à la présidentielle on va
en parler
vous êtes avec nous pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale bonjour
stéphane bern et bonjour stéphane qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france on commence par les
régionales fabien roussel puisqu'on a vu
ce sondage bva pour rtl qui est paru
hier dans les eaux de france xavier
bertrand est en tête au premier tour à
33%
il est talonné par sébastien chenu le
candidat du rassemblement national à 31%
et derrière mais un peu loin derrière à
17% votre liste d'union de la gauche
menée par karima delli
est ce que ces chiffres vous des soirées
ce que vous dites ça a peut-être été une
erreur cette union de la gauche
attendez que l'élection ait lieu quand
même d'abord ce n'est qu'un sondage et
ensuite les listes n'ont même pas été
déposé toutes les listes la campagne n'a
pas véritablement commencé les
programmes ne sont pas connues on
commence donc laisser le temps que
la campagne se lance véritablement et
puis qu'il y ait un vrai débat avec nos
concitoyens en fait la moitié du score
de xavier bertrand dans sondage vous
pensez qu'en six semaines vous pourrez
rattraper tout ça il faut conserver
l'espoir
en tout cas le choix qui a été fait
c'est celle de l'union ou de l'avait dit
et on verra fait que ça fera à la fin ce
qui à mon avis ce qui est déterminant
c'est surtout les idées et les
propositions que nous allons défendre
vous savez dans ma région la semaine
dernière les portes de bridgestone c'est
son terrain fermé pour la dernière fois
cette semaine jeudi
après demain les salariés de la
française de mécanique à douvrin vont
manifester pour demander à ce que le
moteur que peugeot s'était lantiss a
décidé de délocaliser en hongrie soit
réalisée chez nous dans le pas de calais
et donc ses combats industriels sont des
combats surtout s'ils sont
incontournables indispensable
nous devons les mener c'est ce que je
souhaite pouvoir mettre au coeur de
cette campagne régionale nationale parce
que ils sont déterminants pour l'avenir
mais ces chiffres vous alors vous avez
complètement raison de dire que ce ne
sont que des sondages on et voilà la
campagne a pas démarré etc il peut se
passer plein de choses d'accord en même
temps le fait que vous ayez fait union
vous ayez réussi l'union de la gauche
dans cette région ça a été beaucoup dit
beaucoup vu très sucré commenté seraient
dus ou potentiellement ça aurait pu vous
permettre d'avoir quelques points de
plus ce sondage si oui oui ça vous
interroge pas plus que ça c'est sûr que
si que ça m'interroge je suis pas le
contraire mais vous savez avant avant
que cette union les lieux un vous ici et
tant d'autres nous disent me disent il
faut faire l'union faut faire du nouveau
vers l'union belge fait là vous vous
dites
ben c'est marrant ça marche pas bah
mais si je présente si nous faisons le
choix non par exemple de défendre l'idée
modeste que nous pourrions présenter un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle et
de ne pas aller derrière un candidat
unique de toute la gauche
c'est aussi peut-être parce qu'on se dit
que pour aller parler aux français il y
as besoin que chaque idée puisse être
développé que chacun met en avant ses
priorités et pour nous au parti
communiste penser je viens de vous le
dire pour nous la priorité c'est
l'emploi et les salaires c'est des
conditions de travail
c'est l'industrie c'est les services
publics c'est le pouvoir d'achat assez
ces choses là que nous on souhaite
mettre en avant en priorité alors ça va
pas parler à tous les français c'est pas
les priorités tout le monde mais nous
nous pensons que ce sont des choses
importantes que nous devons mettre
aujourd'hui au coeur du débat dans le
pays reprendre le pouvoir sur les
richesses sur l'argent les mettre au
service de tous au service de nos deux
de la santé de l'école regarder les
chiffres que l'on a vu hier sur les plus
riches de notre pays en disant la
fortune des plus riches a augmenté de +
439% on est les champions du monde de
l'accumulation des richesses dans les
mains d'une ultra minorité on est plus
fort que les américains que les
allemands en milliardaire
enfin c'est incroyable is as et ça passe
et ça passe et bien nous non voilà donc
c'est un combat qui nous paraît
prioritaire pour faire en sorte que
chacun puisse vivre dignement avec un
travail et un salaire
voilà alors
allez on va parler des élections
nationales mais nous on veut porter ce
combat là et bien c'est vrai que quand
on fait une liste avec d'autres forces
politiques peut-être que ces idées que
nous portons se voit un petit peu moins
on essaye de les porter au sein de cette
liste dans les hauts de france dans
d'autres disent tu dans d'autres régions
mais sur la même pas convaincu que
c'était le bon choix cette union de la
gauche quand vous entends fabien roussel
bas je vous rappelle qu'au départ
j'avais proposé ma candidature comme
tête de liste pour rassembler tout le
monde parce que justement dans cette
région où le taux de pauvreté est un des
plus élevés de france où le taux de
chômage est de 4 points supérieur à la
moyenne nationale où les questions
industrielles sont si importantes
je pensais modestement que ma
candidature ma connaissance de ces
enjeux là aurait pu faire en sorte
d'aller convaincre un électorat
populaire salariés ouvriers pour pour
que ça change dans cette région bon
c'est pas l'union de problèmes et le
choix de la tête de liste c'est le choix
le choix était fait notamment par
jean-luc mélenchon et la france est
soumise de se rallier avec les verts et
puis ça en sera conditionné tout leur
est bon moi je veux dire que c'est pas
le bon choix mais non je dis pas ça je
dis qu'aujourd'hui sans hélas nous ont
fait un principe de réalité
on s'est dit bon ben si la majorité
pense qu'il faut se rassembler derrière
karima delli bien nous allons y aller et
mais on voit là on va se battre
aujourd'hui pour que cette liste face le
meilleur résultat qu'il y ait le moins
d'abstention possible et puis un dernier
mot là dessus parce que vous
les bons jean luc mélenchon il a l'air
d'y aller - samedi vous étiez tous à
lille pour le défilé du 1er mai y avait
toutes les forces de gauche qui étaient
représentées jean luc mélenchon il a
refusé des filets à vos côtés d'après le
monde il vous aurait dit vous êtes des
faux jetons donc il a refusé
ce défilé est ce que c'est quand même
pas la preuve que l'union de la gauche
dans notre région c'est un peu de la
façade
je moi il m'a pas dit que j'étais un
faux jeton parce que je n'ai pas vu donc
non mais mais parce qu'il y avait
énormément de monde à cette
manifestation
moi j'y suis tous les ans depuis je suis
tout petit donc c'est chez moi mais
c'est ce que j'ai fait et j'ai été très
content d'accueillir tout le monde jean
luc mélenchon et à une pirogue l'élu bon
il y avait beaucoup de parisiens et qui
étaient là tant mieux
et puis et puis voilà bon il a fait son
discours de son côté il à rester dans
son carré venir à lille et ne pas
défiler avec vous c'est quoi c'est la
faux mélangent à défiler ensemble faut
pas dire ça
on a d'abord je vous rappelle que le 1er
mai c'est là là là c'est le
rassemblement des travailleurs ça
s'organise à l'appel des organisations
syndicales
moi j'avais dit attention à ne pas
kidnappé cette manifestation qui est
celle des organisations syndicales et du
monde du travail et donc faut y aller
modestes ou quoi présents mais pas
pesant comme on dit et donc voilà mais
tout ça c'est du cinéma enfin une
dernière chose sur les élections
régionales en eau de france si jamais au
deuxième tour vous voyez vous percevez
que le rassemblement national a une
chance de gagner la région à la faveur
d'une triangulaire d'une quadrangulaire
est ce que est ce que vous retirerez ce
que vous retirez votre liste ou alors
est-ce que cette époque là et est
complètement évolué d'abord je dirais
pas qu'il ya une chanson je dirais qu'il
ya un risque
et puis
vous y avez pensé vous en parlez entre
vous bien sûr et quelle est la décision
nous avons toujours été clairs là dessus
c'est que on ne prendra jamais le risque
que l'extrême droite française puisse
diriger des collectivités une région où
le pays donc si le risque est avéré
volet sortira on veut on verra à ce
moment-là ce que je vois quand même même
si ce ne sont que des sondages c'est que
le candidat de l'extrême droite dans
cette région fait quand même beaucoup
moins que
qu'en 2015 donc marine le pen en 2015
donc le risque qu'il est quand même
moins grand mais il est encore présent
c'est inquiétant et d'ailleurs quand je
vois qu'en france la et dans d'autres
régions c'est la droite et l'extrême
droite lui qui domine c'est inquiétant
pour l'avenir c'est inquiétant pour la
suite ça veut dire que les valeurs
libérales
et d'extrême droite sont majoritaires
dans le pays
donc vous comprenez bien que dans cette
situation les valeurs de gauche de
justice sociale d'égalité sociale de
fraternité ces valeurs-là elles
deviennent minoritaires et et ça doit ça
devrait donc nous inquiéter montrer
qu'il est urgent de pouvoir remettre
cette question sociale au coeur de au
coeur de nos combats ce qu'ils se jouent
en provence alpes côte d'azur ça vous
surprend pas ça me surprend pas du tout
vous saviez vous saviez que ça ne
m'étonne pas mais enfin à l'assemblée
nationale c'est quand même faux cul et
compagnie entre les républicains et l
excès est en marche parce que ils sont
quand même d'accord sur des sujets très
comment dire très important pour le
budget ils sont d'accord ensemble pour
ne pas rétablir l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune il était d'accord pour le
supprimer
il était d'accord pour supprimer la taxe
sur les dividendes il était d'accord
pour mettre un bouclier fiscal qui
plafonne à 30% les impôts sur les
revenus financiers
enfin sur toutes ces questions liées à
l'argent les cadeaux aux plus riches
la baisse des impôts des multinationales
pas des pme la baisse des impôts des
multinationales sur toutes ces questions
là ils sont sur la même longueur d'onde
à la gagne quand même qu'on s'en fasse
sur la ligne de renaud muselier pour le
conte puisqu'il soutient chinamasa
d'accord c'est du cinéma dont ils vont
suspendre renault mise au lit pendant
six mois et vont le réintégrer après
quand israel et moi non mais ils sont
quand même d'accord sur le fond et sur
ses principaux sujets financiers
ils ne veulent pas s'attaquer à
l'évasion fiscale ensemble les mêmes
moi j'ai défendu un texte de loi pour
établir une véritable liste de paradis
fiscaux j'ai proposé prélèvement à la
source des bénéfices des multinationales
comme on le fait pour nos revenus mais
ils sont d'accord pour rejeter toutes
ces propositions de lois c'est ça va
trop loin pour eux c'est trop dur donc
ça ne m'étonne pas qu'ils puissent se
mettre d'accord sur des listes est
justement va parler de la crise
économique et de la crise sociale
stéphane oui on a on sait que les aides
aux entreprises seront maintenus
l'intégralité du fonds de solidarité au
mois de mai va être maintenu à 10
bruno le maire est
est-ce que vous approuvez la lah cette
sortie progressive du quoi qu'il en
coûte est ce que c'est la bonne méthode
de conserver les aides transitoires ou
est ce qu'il faudrait passer à autre
chose plus rapidement d'abord qu'il y
ait beaucoup d'argent public
miho pour sortir de cette crise c'est
important nous avons toujours été nous
du côté de ceux justement qui disent il
faut une intervention de l'état et donc
qu'il faut injecter de l'argent public
pour soutenir l'économie nos services
publics nos bons la question qui se pose
c'est comment on utilise cet argent au
service de quelle politique
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que on a
eu un rapport à l'assemblée nationale et
il y a quinze jours de cela il y à 140
milliards d'euros de dettes publiques
versées aux entreprises par l'état les
collectivités sous forme de subvention
de près de crédit d'impôt 140 milliards
d'euros par an sans aucune condition
sans rien demander en échange et c'est
là où il ya un problème
d'abord parce qu'une grande partie les
deux tiers de ces aides sont captés par
les grosses entreprises et que les pme
les artisans les petites boîtes en ont
une infime partie et d'autre part cette
cette masse d'argent public est versée
aux grandes multinationales à déverser
sans rien leur demander
et donc on a des boîtes comme renault
qui par exemple en prend une grande
partie je crois que renault c'est 7
milliards et de l'autre côté renault
délocalise la production de sa future
dacia spring électriques en chine
renault décide de d2 de maintenir la
production de fonte en turquie et en
espagne
au lieu de la rapatrier au fonderie de
bretagne où les salariés sont en grève
et je les salue d'ailleurs parce qu'ils
défendent leur outil de travail et ils
ont bien raison de le faire
comme beaucoup de fonderie dans notre
pays et donc ce n'est pas acceptable que
l'on puisse accorder des prêts des aides
publiques de l'argent public et notre
argent à des boîtes qui derrière
délocalisent et j'ai tellement faire on
peut pas et ça c'est donc il peut y
avoir une aide pour la sortie de crise
pour la relance du pays
oui
mais il faut conditionner ses aides il
faut que ça bouleverse nos modes de
production il faut associer les salariés
au choix à l'utilisation de cet argent
je suis pour le partage des richesses
vous l'avez entendu je suis aussi pour
le partage des pouvoirs etc au sein des
entreprises les salariés eux mêmes
puissent dire que cet argent public
serait utile pour moderniser tel outil
travail pour acheter telle machine pour
former tel salarié mais ça c'est sur la
question des fonderies puisque c'est un
c'est un sujet vous suivez
particulièrement fière l'état octroyant
un prêt pour éviter la liquidation
fonderie dans l'inde et dans la vienne
c'est un prêt de 10 millions d'euros
vous dites c'est bien vous dit c'est pas
la bonne méthode non non non je dis j'ai
été les voir les salariés des fonderies
du poitou je peux vous dire que leur
angoisse est grande ce prêt va répondre
à la situation d'urgence et c'est
d'éviter la liquidation
donc ça répond mais si c'est le pré
point barre ça ne suffira pas puisque le
problème des fonderies du poitou c'est
de pouvoir continuer à produire la balle
et de mémoire des carter qui servent à
renault notamment
et donc ce qu'il faut c'est que renault
donne de la charge à cette fonderie
comme elle doit le faire pour la
fonderie de bretagne
elle doit donner de la charge de travail
comment voulez-vous que peugeot et
renault donne de la charge de travail à
ses usines
si ils délocalisent leurs véhicules à
l'étranger
j'ai parlé de la dacia sprint pour
renault mais peugeot va délocaliser la
c5 en chine
voilà enfin et c'est le fond en recevant
de l'argent public l'argent des
contribuables on doit mettre un coup
d'arrêt à ces délocalisations c'est une
question d'urgence vitale pour notre
pays si on débranche l'industrie de
notre pays mais on meurt c'est comme une
fin et c'est comme un goutte-à-goutte
quoi on a perdu un million d'emplois en
l'espace de dix ans il faut arrêter
c'est le grand déménagement industriel
dans notre pays on doit y mettre un coup
d'arrêt ça je peux vous dire que dans la
campagne des présidentielles
c'est ce que je souhaite mettre en débat
chacun se déterminera mais il faut une
loi immédiates pour stopper les
délocalisations dans notre pays une loi
pure et simple qui interdit
les délocalisations c'est possible ça
peut être fait en quelques semaines et
au moins on arrêtera le grand
déménagement industriel
outre les délocalisations vous allez
maintien de l'emploi vous et vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure la situation lui
jean l'usiné bridgestone de béthune qui
a définitivement perdre fermé ses portes
vendredi dernier sur les 8 163 salariés
et en rials environ 500 qui sont sans
emploi on à la ministre anne espagne
winch et qui évoque neuf projets de
reprise ou de reconversion de deux
transformations d'emplois est ce que
vous êtes confiant est-ce que vous
pensez que la sueur sur ce dossier là ce
que vous reconnaissez que le
gouvernement agit comme il faut pas non
non mais qu'est ce qui n'a pas été
choisi cette usine dont vous n'êtes pas
confiant sera non maintenant mais cette
usine a été créé en 1961 elle a pas
retenu des américains des japonais
elle aurait pu elle a changé de mains
plusieurs fois demain elle aurait pu
appartenir à des chinois qui avaient un
projet de reprise
aujourd'hui c'est en amont qu'il aurait
fallu interview aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de pneus pour le marché français
demain les pneus qui était fait à
bridgestone seront faits en hongrie vont
revenir en france par camion c'est
normal face qu'on a fait dans la loi des
choses sur le site non 28 non non non
non pas du tout ah non non c'est parce
que la commission européenne avec la
complicité de la france a accepté de
subventionner à hauteur de 50 millions
d'euros je crois bridgestone pour
élargir pour augmenter les capacités de
production de son usine en hongrie
donc c'est la concurrence distorsions de
concurrence instaurée par l'union
européenne et bien sûr cette union
européenne cette europe libérale que
défendre en marche les républicains la
droite c'est celle qui broie qui tuent
notre industrie c'est parce qu'ils ont
les ouvriers en concurrence entre eux
ils mettent en concurrence l'ouvrier
polonais au droit espagnol avec
l'ouvrier français et à la fin c'est
tous les ouvriers qui perdent au final
parce que l' usine elle part en hongrie
mais ils sont pas
bree les cabanes hongrois que dans cinq
ans il décide de la délocaliser en
slovénie ou ailleurs et aujourd'hui
c'est trop tard qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le qu'est-ce
que dans ce qui est proposé ou ce qui
est envisagé par le gouvernement pour le
site
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui manque
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire mais ce qu'il faut faire c'est
conserver nos capacités de production
donc là le le site de bridgestone les
actionnaires ont décidé de fermer ça va
prendre quelques mois je peux si en deux
ans mais 2022 dans douze mois
si un changement de gouvernement avec un
gouvernement et un président de la
république ce que je souhaite qu'ils
décident de stopper toutes les
délocalisations et de relocaliser
l'activité industrielle nous devrons
faire en sorte que à bridgestone
on continue de produire des pneus pour
nos véhicules
parce que c'est possible et c'est pas en
mai que l'on créé d'aider d'autres
activités à côté dans lequel la des
salariés pour y retrouver du travail
pourquoi pas ça veut dire qu'il ya des
activités à créer mais ça doit venir en
plus de celle ci il ne faut pas renoncer
la sellette mais parce que il ya un taux
de chômage dans le bassin de de béthune
qui est élevé vié puis pour tous ses
salariés
je les connais ses salariés c'est leur
vie c'est leur vie c'est une vie sociale
cds a mis ses des collègues
tout tourne autour de bridgestone vous
leur enlevez la vie et donc non
seulement on a besoin de cette
production mais en plus c'est important
pour la vie sociale de ce bassin est
donc créons les conditions pour que dans
sept usines
on continue de produire ce dont nous
avons besoin pour notre filière
automobile on n'achète pas moins de
véhicules aujourd'hui on continue d'en
acheter plus il ya 47 % des véhicules du
parc automobile français qui ne sont pas
aux normes environnementales
il va falloir l'échangé ses véhicules
donc il va y avoir un renouvellement du
parc automobile
donc on va voir
loin d'une usine de production de pneus
en france et la breeders dernière
question sur le social on a vu les
manifestations du 1er mai alors qu'ils
se sont passés dans le calme dans
beaucoup d'endroits en france mais il ya
encore eu des heures il ya encore eu des
blessés notamment à paris des militants
de la cgt ont été attaqués est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça vous inquiète sur la
mobilisation sociale ça vous inquiète
sur les manifestations syndicales
est ce que vous dites on pourra plus
manifester calmement à l'avenir quoi ça
fait un moment qu'on dit que c'est de
plus en plus de difficile d'aller
défiler avec en famille avec ses enfants
sur les épaules mais quand je disais
quelques minutes que les valeurs de
droite et d'extrême droite domine sans
ce pays dans domine dans ce pays
eh bien ça se traduit aussi par ces
manifestations de violence au sein des
manifestations et y compris à l'encontre
des syndicalistes de la cgt c'est
terrible c'est vrai alors la droite mais
c'est par rapport aux valeurs d'écouté
aux valeurs d'extrême droite aux valeurs
les propos homophobes racistes sexistes
c'était clairement des militants
d'extrême droite bah ouais mais enfin
elle aimait qui sont en noir cagoulés
enfin des naissains barbie en noir et
cagoulés dans les années aussi la glande
a levé le black block c'est une méthode
et c'est une méthode qui peut utiliser
partout c'est une méthode l'ultra gauche
comme ultra droite
enfin il ya pas c'est une méthode
fasciste qui a rien à voir avec la
gauche ce sont les nôtres à gauche
l'utilisent beaucoup de blé moi je leur
laisse
c'est tout mais de nous permettez-moi de
le dire
responsable du parti communiste français
j'ai entendu philippe martinez exprimé
sur ses propos les forces syndicales de
progrès les forces de gauche 1-2 progrès
caractérise ce genre d'agissements comme
des méthodes fascistes voilà parce que
c'est la violence c'est la violence
enfin et puis en plus j'ai entendu dire
cgt collabos j'ai pensé à henri krasucki
qui a été le grand leader de la cgt et
qui a été interné résistant pendant la
guerre et faire ça la cgt enfin mais
c'est un un retournement ccc ces termes
quand même hein mais ils sont une
minorité cc groupusculaire à ça fait du
bruit mais voilà c'est révélateur aussi
d'un climat c'est pour ça qu'on doit
résister résister résister comme
toujours et un dernier mot sur votre
candidature à la présidentielle stéphane
oui alors le vous ce week end les
militants du parti vont se devront voter
sur votre candidature à la
présidentielle
comment est ce que vous envisagez les
choses d'abord vous ferez l'unanimité au
sein de votre propre famille et ensuite
quel sera le message que que vous
porterez bien d'abord on va laisser les
militants les adhérents du parti
communiste français de confirmer notre
confiance et c'est le vote va commencer
d'ici deux jours
et ils sont près de cinquante mille à
s'exprimer il y a eu un vote majoritaire
lors de la conférence nationale qui
avait réuni 1000 délégués
j'espère je souhaite je pense que
normalement la même une majorité il dont
il devrait s'exprimer mais je peux pas
préjuger c'est une consultation savez
chez nous la démocratie
on y veille comme le lait sur le feu
nous aurons à la fin la de cette semaine
on va avoir voté trois fois faire pour
décider de notre choix
une fois au conseil national une fois en
conférence nationale et à la fin ce sont
les adhérents souverain qui choisissent
ses traits à censurer bretagne était
saturé de sa division mais au début du
mois une lettre de cadres et de
militants que un peu critique notre
choix de vous porter candidat à la
présidentielle est ce que vous craignez
que votre stratégie d'e mails votre
parti ne voyez pas ça comme de la
division moi je vois ça comme du débat
et c'est un débat enrichissant c'est à
dire que ceux qui doutent de ce choix là
nous en discutons et je peux comprendre
les interrogations et nous continuons
d'en discuter et après ce vote on
continuera d'en discuter parce que il y
avait peu après le jeune soldat qui veut
être candidat mais ceci une fois que le
choix sera fait nous irons j'irai
jusqu'au bout quand il sera fait mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que les débats
qui existe au sein de notre parti enfin
on est un parti important
plus de cinq mille élus près de
cinquante mille adhérents forcément
qu'il ya du débat mais heureusement et
donc on va continuer d'en débattre
ce que je veux dire c'est cette question
démocratique le fait que nous quand on
prend une décision
eh bien oui on vote trois fois et c'est
les adhérents à la fin fallait les
militants la base qui choisit c'est pour
vous dire que dans notre projet de
société pour la france et même de la
même manière on met la démocratie au
coeur c'est à chaque fois les citoyens
qui doivent décider comme nous on fait
dans notre force politique il faut
véritablement et définitif y aura un
candidat communiste y aura pas de taxe
hymne de la gauche si dimanche soir à 17
heures la décision est prise elle sera
prise pour aller jusqu'au mois de mai
merci beaucoup merci fabien roussel
d'avoir été notre invité regarde là une
de ouest france est la loi climat que
les députés doivent voter cet après-midi
bientôt la fin des centres commerciaux
géants c'est à la une de ouest france
merci mission
[Musique]